you and I would probably spend $1,000 on
TV and be happy but this guy James L
Doan spent
3.6 billion that's billion with a B for
Barry building the MSG sphere and it's
not even the price tag that's half the
problem you see James is no stranger to
ambitious projects as the executive
chairman and CEO of the Madison Square
Garden company he's known for pushing
the boundaries of entertainment however
the MSG sphere in Las Vegas takes things
to a whole new level the sphere features
the largest high resolution LED screens
in the world providing an immersive
visual experience that can be seen from
any seat inside or outside of the venue
located proudly in the heart of Las
Vegas this colossal structure is unlike
anything you've ever seen it's not just
the immersive size that's impressive
it's also the immersive experiences it
promises to provide we're talking about
the ultimate entertainment Hub with
state-ofthe-art audio and visuals all in
one space so what's the challenge with
this extravagant project well that's
what we're here to uncover as we explore
the MSG sphere further we'll unveil the
architectural hurdles and the
innovations that accompany it while
understanding its origins of course
let's start by imagining a dozen
football fields stretch side by side
that's just the surface area of the
sphere it's like a vast canvas on an
epic scale ready to paint the sky with
mesmerizing visuals to truly grasp the
immense height of the sphere pictures
stacking three boing 747 airplanes one
on top of another it's all inspiring to
the point it took the world's fourth
largest crane to complete the
construction not to mention it took 18
days just to build the crane with
another crane the sphere's
groundbreaking design is obviously a
spherical shape that defies traditional
architecture offering a futuristic and
iconic appearance it's rumored that the
works are already underway to construct
a similar venue in London followed suit
with many more around the world but it's
not about the size it's the magic that
unfolds after the sun sets as Darkness
Falls the sphere comes to life turning
the Las Vegas Skyline into a captivating
spectacle but why you may be asking what
is the point of all of this well those
colossal LED screens aren't just for
show they're an integral part of the MSG
sphere's Magic from an architectural
standpoint these screens are a Marvel of
innovation they utilize advanced LED
technology similar to what you find in
Time Square but on a whole new scale
these screens can display images videos
and even realtime data transforming the
sphere into a dynamic canvas picture a
journey through outer space or even a
Tropical Paradise these screens can
create immersive experiences like no
other blurring the lines between reality
and Imagination the sphere isn't just a
building it is a Stage IT hosts live
performances with these screens at the
heart of the show they complement live
acts with stunning visual effects
creating a multi- sensory experience
that's truly Unforgettable the Colossal
screens also serve as a massive
information Hub whether it's realtime
data updates news or event announcements
they keep you informed with just a touch
of grandeur what truly sets these
screens apart is their ability to
immerse you in a
360° visual experience it's like the
building becomes a Living Canvas
transforming its appearance with each
passing moment both from the inside and
the out but we'll get to that regardless
of whether it's daylight or Darkness the
$3.6 billion TV is always ready to
impress during the day they function
like giant Windows allowing natural
light to filter through as night falls
they come alive Illuminating the Las
Vegas Skyline in breathtaking ways let's
take a step back a $3.6 billion
entertainment Hub doesn't simply appear
out of thin air it requires Vision hard
work and the collaboration of many to
bring this to life the construction of
the sphere is not just about creating an
architectural Marvel it's about
transforming the city of Las Vegas the
impact of this colossal structure on the
city at his residence is truly
remarkable now the story of the sphere
begins with Madison Square Garden
entertainment Corporation also known as
MSG entertainment hence MSG sphere MSG
entertainment is a renowned
entertainment company with iconic venues
such as Madison Square Garden in New
York the Forum in California and the
Chicago Theater they have a rich history
of Hosting worldclass events concer and
entertainment spectacles in their
pursuit of creating an innovative
entertainment venue MSG entertainment
partnered with Stadium design
architectural practice populace and
Builder aom originally the sphere was
expected to take several years to
complete to start breaking ground on the
sphere September 27th 2018 considering
the time and effort required to design a
stadium of this caliber it's safe to
assume that the idea had been in the
development for years if not decades
before James as you may recall played a
pivotal role in bringing this Vision to
life his leadership at MSG entertainment
embarked on a mission to create a venue
that would not only be architecturally
grand but also incorporate Cutting Edge
technology the construction of the
sphere began with Las Vegas as its home
however it opened its doors on September
29th
2023 with the famous rock band You2
starting a 36 show residency this
accomplishment is particularly
impressive considering that a global
pandemic occurred during construction
process the sphere is poised to attract
both tourists and locals alike however
the impacts go beyond the Aesthetics it
serves an economical Catalyst for Los
Angeles creating jobs boasting tourism
and revitalizing the surrounding area
all contributing to the city's
prosperity in essence the sphere is more
than just a building it's a symbol of
innovation growth and progress it
showcases the remarkable achievements of
human Ingenuity whilst enriching the
city and the residents however as we
explore the impressive features of The
Spar there is one important drawback
that you need to be aware of keep
watching to learn more about the
significant downsides of this
technological Marvel now that we've
glimpsed at the exterior of the sphere
it's time to venture inside and explore
the vast world of possibilities it
offers as you step inside the sphere
you'll be greeted by a world of
Limitless possibilities it's a space
where technology entertainment and
Architectural Innovation converge with a
capacity of up to 20,000 people standing
or 18,600 seated the sphere offers a
unique seating design that allows for
flexible configurations making it ideal
for various types of events one of the
most extraordinary features is its
ability to transport you to an entirely
new realm imagine being in the heart of
an enchanted forest one moment and the
next on the surface of Mars the sphere's
immersive technology takes you on
Journeys Beyond Your Wildest train
whether it's a mind-blowing concert a
thrilling sports event or a mesmerizing
visual display the sphere can adapt to
every need it's like having a Swiss army
knife of entertainment venues in your
pocket now here's the fascinating part
from an architectural perspective the
spar's dynamic screens transform the
space these colossal LED screens can
create visual Landscapes that are not
just for watching they invite you to be
a part of the action it's like living
inside a movie where you're both the
audience and the STA the sm's
interactive technology doesn't stop
there it can adopt different events and
audiences if it's a rock concert the
Acoustics are tailor made for the best
audio experience if it's a sports event
you're right in the heart of the action
the sphere features the world's largest
fully integrated concert grade audio
system called sphere immersive design
developed by sphere studios in
partnership with 3D innovator Hol plot
this groundbreaking audio system is
1,500 86 permanently installed
loudspeaker modules 300 mobile
loudspeaker modules
and
167,000 speaker drivers along with
amplifiers and processing channels the
system is designed for crystal clear
individualized sound to every seat in
the venue revolutionizing immersive
audio experiences this Innovative audio
technology will enhance the overall
experience of concerts and events held
in the sphere providing an an
unparalleled audio Journey for the
audience the system utilizes beam
forming technology to direct sound to
specific locations instead of
traditional speakers placed throughout
the venue this revolutionary technology
will transform the way sound is
delivered to audiences creating an
acoustic sweet spot for every single
person now if you're looking to embark
on an architectural Journey whether it's
a dream home or the unlikely
multi-billion dollar entertainment venue
it all begins with a crystal clear
project brief over the past decade I've
seen the power of well structured briefs
without one projects often lose
direction and cost significantly more
than they should that's why I've
designed the client's DIY architectural
brief a simple drag and drop template
populated with your vision this can help
create a cohesive document that will set
your project apart please don't leave
your architectural dreams to chance head
over to our website grab your DIY brief
today the link is in the description
below and because you haven't skipped
over this section messing with the
algorithm use the code Sphere for 50%
off the DIY brief the MSG sphere is not
just a colossal series of LED screens
it's also a vision of a bright future
brought to life pun intended the LED
screens consist of tiny light emitting
LEDs that emit light when electronic
current passes through them these LEDs
are arranged in a regular array red
green and blue dots allowing the screen
to produce millions of different Colors
by combining these basic three colors in
different proportions what sets the
lighting system apart is it the 1.2
million individual LEDs but it's the
ability to create threedimensional
effects adding depth and dimension to
the visuals the LED screens used in the
sphere are designed to be immersive and
interactive consisting of hexagonal
panels that can be moved and rotated to
create various shapes and patterns
equipped with sensors these panels can
detect movement of the performers on
stage and respond accordingly resulting
in a dynamic synchronized visual
experience with music Advanced
projection mapping technology on the LED
screens can be powered with the most
basic tools your laptop and in the M
future even your iPhone projection
mapping involves projecting images onto
irregular shapes and objects or surfaces
to create the illusion of movement or
depth when you step into the sphere it's
not just about what you see or here it's
about what you feel the lining
technology at the heart of this
immersive Journey turns the building
into an unbelievable experience now
let's explore the eco-friendly aspect of
the sphere the Colossal architectural
wonder is not just about entertainment
and Technology but it's also designed
with a strong commitment to
sustainability the sphere proudly boasts
a green heart making it an eco-friendly
Marvel it goes beyond the biggest and
brightest the construction of the sphere
utilizes sustainable and eco friendly
building materials including recyclable
materials and low impact components
minimizing the environmental footprint
and thanks to a partnership with Envy
energy the sphere sources are staggering
70% of its energy from the Sun Energy
Efficiency is at the core of the
sphere's design meticulously engineered
LED screens lighting and other systems
ensure low power consumption whilst
delivering a remarkable experience the
MSG sphere is actively pursuing Green
Building certifications to formalize its
eco- friendly design with so many people
inside waste reduction Recycling and
environmental responsible practices are
integral to the sphere's commitment
sustainable operations are given top
priority when hosting events at the MSG
sphere from Water Management to effluent
waste disposal every aspect is
considered to ensure long-term
environmental Consciousness whilst the
sphere is an impressive architectual
feet it has not escaped criticism one
major point of contention is a sphere's
size and Des design which has sparked
intense debates and discussions amongst
locals Architects and urban platters
these debates often revolve around the
potential impact of the sphere on the
iconic Las Vegas Skyline raising
concerns about its effects on the city's
Aesthetics Harmony and its famous
panoramic views whilst some individuals
argue the sphere's presence May disrupt
the existing visual balance and
compromise the city's unique charm
others believe it could serve as a bold
and innovative addition that enhances
the architectural diversity of Las Vegas
let me know in the comments down below
what your opinion is construction
challenges have also Arisen during the
development of this project building
something of this magnitude and
complexity is not without its fair share
of hurdles and obstacles with the scale
of the project it's not uncommon to
encounter delays cost overruns and
logistical issues that need to be
addressed and overcome these challenges
have not gone unnoticed as they have
garnered significant attention and
scrutiny from various stakeholders
involved in the project it is crucial to
navigate through these challenges
effectively to ensure the success and
completion of a project additionally
despite the eco-friendly features
environmentalists have raged questions
about the overall impact of such a
massive structure on local ecosystems
with 20,000 people traffic is a
significant concern as well a venue of
this size there will be substantial
increases in visitors managing traffic
flow and parking could present its own
challenges and of course we cannot
Overlook the obvious when it comes to
the sphere's Grand events it is crucial
to take into account the issues of sound
and light pollution these factors play a
significant role in the overall impact
that these events might have on
surrounding areas the potential
consequences should not be
underestimated as they could potentially
affect the quality of life of nearby
residents and visitors anyway that's all
from me team if you've enjoyed this
video consider subscribing for new
content
weekly